let's go next to our caller from the
3:01
area code there is something a little
funky going on with the call system
today but we're gonna do our best to uh
sort of work within what is available to
us so who's calling from 301 today hey
David this is Jason
hey Jason what's going on oh yeah my
question is about fake news and what we
can do to combat it and if the
government should have any role in that
so I'm I'm becoming increasingly
concerned about big news and these
conspiracy movements I'm such like can't
Eve acts movements and you know like Fox
News is a defending Trump at all cost
and they're not grounded in reality and
things like climate change they just
deny it when all scientists pretty much
say it's real so I'm wondering what you
think we can do to combat it and if the
government should have any have any role
in combating it so the problem is that
when you get to the point of arguing
about or thinking about whether the
government should have any role it's
sort of already too late like if if we
have a society where we need the
government to combat fake news we've
already sort of lost and this goes back
to what I've been talking about I talked
about it earlier this week we have on
almost total lack of schools teaching
people to really think for themselves to
understand epistemology to understand
critical thinking and if and until we
have that the the government combating
fake news by putting restrictions on
Facebook or whatever the case may be
it's too late in the process we need to
be attacking this far far earlier now if
someone has a particular proposal as to
something that could be done by law to
try to quote fight fake news I'm not
opposed to it reflexively like on
principle I'm open to listening to it
but the problem is that if we had more
adults who just under
and media literacy understand
epistemology understand arguments
understand how to determine for
themselves whether a conclusion that is
being fed to us actually follows from
the premises and whether the premises
are precise and accurate we wouldn't be
having the conversation about this
government need to need to deal with
this that's not the reality government
is in the picture because things have
gotten so bad but it needs to really be
dealt with systemically starting far
earlier than when we would just say
government needs to fix it right yeah I
agree with that I almost think it's too
late at this point I mean there's just
like so many people there just like a
little college yeah I mean it's never
too late to start educating people but
at this point a lot of people lack the
skills to really figure it out for
themselves
unfortunately exactly all right well
thank you okay Jason from Maryland
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much